the preparation for win the  two world championship is a lot of long  because  we work a lot in the altitude and then a  specific work with like a  long sector like a prayer space  and when you do that  your eyes really really die in the  evening  at the moment for the nutrition i use uh  usually the practice for the training  for the race they get a full jazz with  the  maltodextrin i like too much because uh  when you use it with the fructose you  have immediately the energy in the legs  and you can spin well  i think the difference to the road race  and the contrary is just you are alone  and the reason for the people you are  just you are your bike and the coach in  the car and sometimes it's not like  listen  a lot  in the end  is important spin well and then  give the result